From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Monday September 26, 2011. My name is Joe Manier of the Southern Oral History Program.
At the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill, I'm with the videographer John W. Walker Bishop in Little Rock, Arkansas, Arkansas,
to do an oral history interview for the Civil Rights History Project, which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
And we're very privileged today to be with Ms. Carrie Lamar, young in Little Rock, Arkansas at her home.
And this young thank you very much for the warm welcome. That's nice to be with your little privilege.
I'm very honored. Thank you.
Let me start. If I could, with having you talk just a little bit about your family, your community, coming up in Barton, Arkansas.
Okay. Well, my parents, Lazarus Lamar and my mom, Lytte Lamar, gave birth to four girls, two boys, which I was the youngest of the four girls.
I don't remember actually living at Barton. I remember living at Lexa, which was about four or five miles from Barton.
And we lived there in Lexa until I was, I think, 14. And we lived, moved to West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
But doing my stay in Lexa, we actually did sharecropping, raised our own gardens, raised our own cows, chickens, hogs, worked the cotton fields.
That was before soybeans came in. So I was glad to see soybeans.
Then I had to pick so much cotton, the chop so much cotton.
We had our own depot where the train came through and we could catch the train and ride the train from Lexa to hell on a down on Cherry Street and do our shopping and stuff.
That was exciting. And we all, all the children always got a chance to go with mom when she went shopping in hell on her.
Tell me a little bit about your parents as a person.
Well, my dad, he was, I think he went through the third grade, but educationally speaking, he was a real sharp man, very smart.
He loved math. He worked in an ice plant that we had in Lexa.
And didn't do much work with us and the field mom was in the field with us.
She was a midwife. She delivered most of the babies in our area.
And not just any midwife either, but she was the midwife that if there was a breach baby coming into the world, people would come and find her because she had that skill in our hands.
I call it the laying on her hands. That she knew how to manipulate the womb and get that baby to turn around so it could come out right now.
When I was 23, I found out that my mom didn't know how to read or write.
She was actually able to conceal that from me. I don't know if the rest of the children knew it or not, but she was able to conceal that from me until I was 23.
Did they come up in that area? The Delta Arkansas, that were their families.
When my mom was born in Yazoo City, Mississippi, and my dad was born in Palestine, Arkansas, which is right outside of Forest City between Memphis and Brinkley.
And my dad and mom both grew up on plantations, which one of my uncles gave me some real depth information about their history and what they names were before it became Lamar.
Most black people don't like to talk about that. They kind of keep it hush hush because they don't want to identify what they pass.
Most of the elders in my family because of my participation in the civil rights movement, they felt like I needed all about our family that they could share with me.
So my uncle Virgil, who was, he worked in the steel mills in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania for years.
And when he would come home, you know, he was like, I'll tell you whatever you want to know, you know, just ask.
So that's what I did. And learning a lot of things about my dad's side of the family from their plantation name was Raymond.
But once they left the plantation, my great-great-grandfather changed their name to Lamar, where he came up with Lamar, my uncle didn't know that.
But he did share that much with me. And my dad came from a family of like ten sisters and twelve, it was twelve boys.
And my grandfather lived with us for a while when we was in Lexington. He lived to be like 104 before he passed away.
And my mom's side of the family, I really didn't know that many of them. Her dad, I know that last time mom died when he was pretty young.
So she had a sister in Memphis named Fannie Brown. And both of her brothers lived in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
Well, when I lived at Barton, James Bell lived at Barton. And George Bell lived in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas. And that's a slew of children.
I mean, a large, large family, but close.
Your grandfather lived to be 104? And you said he lived with you when you were a child. So depending on when he presumed, and that he had been born from the 18th.
In 1818, because he died about 1960. It was in 1960 something.
He whittled too. He whittled and made us rings and musical instruments. He would make us rings out of buttons and stuff like that.
And make us flutes out of the bamboo stalks or stems, whatever you call them.
So we looked forward to him coming there spending time with us. He spent so many months with us. And then I had an aunt named Amy Bessie.
That her name was Bessie Lipsy, L.I.P.S.C. White. And they lived out in an area called LaGrange L.A. Capital G.R.A. and G.E.
And she had like 13 children. Well, he would stay with them sometime. And then he would come and stay with us sometime.
And we looked forward to that. There was always awesome time. A lot of our family had moved to Chicago in the spring. And some of them would come visit us.
We just looked forward to that. That was like Christmas for us.
Tell me about your home and where exactly you lived in LaGrange?
Okay. My home in Lexa was a triplex shotgun house. I mean, it was three houses in one building. But all three houses were shotgun units.
We lived on one end. It was a single lady named Miss Mary that lived in the middle. And then the Walker family lived on the other end. The Walker family had about a husband and wife and 14 children.
And they all lived in those three rooms. It was really rural. My dad hunted mostly in one of the time for the meats that we ate.
At that time in our life, we still had smoke houses. So when somebody killed slaughtered a hog or a cow, they would get together and do that.
And the backyard would be full of those big old cast iron pots that set over stack of wood or whatever had like the three legs on it.
And we cleaned chitlins, washed, we had number three tub just lined up. You get all the waste out of one on one to rinse them into the other one, take them over to the other one and today got pearly white.
And I mean, you could see like an open ring. You could see those colors in the entrails after they were cleaned. We did cracklings right out there where you would take that fat back and throw it over in the grease.
We actually created its own grease. You just put it in a hot pot. And after a while, the grease would begin to bubble on the top and then cracklings would float up to the top.
And I mean, you know, that was just a heyday.
How about school? School was, it was necessary. It was important. It was significant in our lives. But in my younger years in school, we would get taken out of school to make sure we had ample enough income and supplies and things that we need to get us through the winter.
So the books that we had, most of them didn't have backs on them. Pages were missing because we would get the books that had barred in high school, stamped down on them and something like that or another school.
And that's what we had to do our studies from.
I guess I got a little bit fortunate because of me being the youngest girl. When my sister that's a year older me started to school, I started to school too.
So I got to jump start on everything and being a girl too in my age, I didn't get pulled out of school as much as some of my other siblings did because I couldn't do what they could do.
So I helped Mama to quilt to can. I got chance to watch over 300 fruit jars every year and make sure that, you know, we had food can to get us through the winter.
Pick pecans, walnuts, the black walnuts, I love black walnuts today.
How did you parents? I was about to ask how your circumstances like that. How did parents help you all the children come to understand how to navigate through Jim Crow, how to be alert to the things that you needed to be alert to.
And how did you get a burden to tell you directly today?
I guess a lot of it was exposure and observing how they handle situations.
And I was the child that my oldest sister named me Minerva because I didn't have a problem asking questions or adventuring out.
And usually when we asked our mom about situations, she would always refer us to the Bible. And I think there may have been one thing that kind of covered up her lack of education for me because to me she had so much wisdom and so much knowledge about different things that I just assumed she could read and write.
And she stayed on top of us to make sure that we could read and write, you know.
But she always, one thing she taught me, she said, don't ever be afraid to ask anybody for anything.
If you need something, ask for it. There's only one or two answers you're going to get this. Yes and no.
So when I needed something, I'd jump over that fear that would come up and go for it. And usually I was blessed.
So I knew instinctively because I had a couple of experiences that went on in our community.
Well one night I noticed my daddy left home with a gun and I knew he wasn't going hunting.
And I asked him where he was going. He said, oh me and the boys were going to hunt some combs.
And when he got to the end of the road, he just all of a sudden disappeared. Then I found out later that it was a situation that went on that day where I wanted to
merchant daughters in the town had accused one of the young black boys of raping or well asking her to have sex with him.
And the father that son had went and handled the situation the best he knew how to handle it with her family.
But something happened that they didn't feel like they needed to take a chance and leave this child to be exposed to whatever might happen once the son went down.
So they guarded the entrance to the community that night by them. They just loaded up both sides of the road with people with shotguns to protect this young man.
Plus the young man that she accused, he was shy and probably had some special needs that was going on in his life.
And it took me years to get my daddy to finally share that information with me of what actually happened that night.
You said there were other things you remember too about incidents as you were going there?
Oh, one, in Lexa where we lived in years that I could remember, I'd say from five years until I was about 13 or 14.
We used to work in the fields and some of the people that we worked for, that white people that was poor like we were, they worked out there then there was every night in Mexicans and Chinese were working out there which always thought was strange.
But they came in from somewhere in cotton.
And one of the young girls, me and her was about the same age. She's always had these conversations with me about what blacks were and weren't and what white people were and weren't and stuff like that.
And when they me and her was having a little altercation up in cotton wagon, my daddy just happened to be walking by when I was getting rid of it.
And I actually picked up, I was fixing the throw over the wagon.
And I did it was like cat. And I put it down and we had exchanged some words, you know, I did some old old science jokes with the call the dozens, you know how you would put people down and stuff.
And I had exchanged all those words and I had got passed that I was just ready to get rid of her, you know.
Of course the Lord sent my dad by to take care of that.
And years later, believe it or not, before my dad passed, I ran into this girl again. She worked for Western Union.
And she was holding up the old black people in Helena, Arkansas.
This is in the late 80s.
And the Western Union closes promptly. Whatever they close in time is, you know, they're going to close down south.
I walked in there with my dad. He was on a Saturday morning.
And he was about six people in the line, about 20 minutes to 12. And she was sitting there on the phone talk.
And I said, these people need to be waited on. He was like, yeah, he's saying they close at 12 o'clock.
And we was going up there to get some money that he was waiting on.
So I walked up to the counter, you know, me and my little bowl cell.
That's excuse me. I'd be with you in the mini-man.
Okay. I go back. She keep right on top. We didn't even look up at the people.
She just on the phone with her little conversation.
So I went back up. That's excuse me. That's what time do you close?
She's at 12 o'clock. I said, when 12 o'clock come, you're going to leave, right?
That's usually the procedure. That's what let me tell you something.
You don't get up out of that chair right now. You won't be sitting in it. Come mind him on.
And she put that phone down. And all the people in there was like, who is this woman?
So when we left my dad and said, do you know who that was?
And I went, no, I don't know. I don't care. I was bad.
You know, I was just really, he said, you remember the wounds that lived in Lexa?
I said, the wounds. He said, yeah, you know the little girl you was going to pitch out the wagon.
And I said, you're a kid. He said, that was her.
I said, she hadn't learned anything yet, actually.
Still don't respect people.
Did Lexa have, did you, you lived in sort of a small town?
Did Lexa have a specific racial geography?
There was a demarcation called the Rural Tracks.
And on one side of the track was the, on our side, the black side was the train station.
You called it from our side. And next to that, at one time we had like a cafe
was across the streets from the train station. So when people were waiting their heads on where they could go sitting.
We had a little garage because a few people had trucks, you know.
They used them for farming and stuff. And then around them, being over here was the Muscleini family
that basically raised all of the vegetables and things for safe way.
And you know, the markets that was in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas and Helena, Arkansas.
And I think they were a German family.
And we did most of our farming. We did with them.
Because you know, you tried to pick the nicer people to work with.
It was another man we used to work for. His name was Homer Tiles. I loved that man. He was a sweet man.
He used to protect me at the way scales because I couldn't pick cotton, a bunch cotton.
I was blessed to pick 100 pounds. And if you didn't get 100 pounds of cotton, in my family you got a weapon right there under the scales.
So I got frequent weapons under the scale.
And a lot of times he would be standing there begging my mom and not to whip me.
So cotton season when we was picking cotton, that was my favorite time of the year.
I didn't like that at all. And that was like my motivation to graduate from high school and leave.
And that's exactly what I did.
How long did the cotton season last?
Normally, I would say, I'm trying to think, is it the August?
We would go start picking cotton sometime. It would go through the fall school season until it got too cold.
Depending on how big the owner's property was. And when it got cold, they did what they called snap cotton or pull cotton.
They would just take the birds and all and leave it to the gin to separate the holes from the cotton.
But before that, you had to get your fingers down in the bulb and pull the cotton out.
Because you didn't have cuticles, they were gone.
And that was my nightmare.
What was the typical day or week in cotton picking season?
Signed up to sundown.
And you were lucky as you said you could get an unkind.
Because you were...
I was small.
For I was picking it and what they call a foot tub.
I would pick it and put it in there and then when they get too heavy for me to actually pick it up, I'd take it and give it to my mom.
And then they had seven foot sacks and they had three foot sacks.
When I did get big enough for a sack, that's what I started.
It was like a three footer.
And it would take me all day long to let things up.
And it wasn't a hundred pounds of cotton when I got through with it.
And I'd be working hard.
But it was just...
You know, as I grew up, I would tell my mom, my hands is not made for picking cotton.
I didn't manchoppin it.
But picking it just wasn't me.
Where were your brothers and age in relation to you?
My youngest brother, he was three years younger than me.
And my oldest brother was five years older than me.
So typically when you started working in cotton harvest, there would have been five children picking.
And then one younger brother.
And what... do you remember what you got paid?
I remember like three fifty a day.
That was my like highest I can remember.
That was for chopping, getting the grass up and around and everything.
And paying you per hundred pounds was something about three dollars for a hundred pounds of cotton.
Then as soon as I left, got out of high school, everything went to ten and twelve dollars.
I was upset about that.
I said, but you know what? One thing about it, I don't have to go back there.
Did your mom get fair treatment at the end of the day picking up the weighing station?
I don't think so.
Now when we got big enough that we knew how to add knowledge, that was my job.
I had to keep everybody's weight when they go up there and me and the owner had to job.
Of course, you didn't get to argue with him too much about what your totals were versus his totals.
With Mr. Home I could do that.
And your father, you said work at the ice plant?
What was his job like?
Did you know how they used to make the hundred pound block size? That's what he did.
In Lexington.
And he also worked at the gin.
So at the gin, the waste cotton that was there, my mom would use that to make quills for the bed and the pillows, stuff like that.
What was your job's job at the cotton gin?
He ginned the cotton.
And he knew how to clean the little folk's things that went around and around to separate the cotton from the hulls.
He could do all of it.
But basically, he was the one up in the thing that would pull that suction part down and get the cotton out of the trailers.
I haven't asked you yet about church.
Church was, I enjoyed it.
I would when nobody else would go.
I would be up every Sunday morning ready to go.
I liked to sing.
There was one pastor that used to come and get my mom to let me go to church with him doing his revival time.
And I would sing for him and the ladies would get happy and thought he'd purses at me and scare me.
I did that with him probably from time I was five.
I was about nine years old.
And then my mom stopped letting me go for some reason.
I guess I was growing up.
I may have said something to her that said it's time for her not to go anymore.
What was the church?
I grew up, our family church was first Baptist church Alexa.
Reverend Devaro was our pastor.
And Mr. I think his name was Gus Wilburn.
He was our superintendent.
He would go and ring the church bell.
And they lived across the field for months about as far as from my house he was from that house over there.
And it was a big old walnut tree that sat in between our houses.
That was my favorite spot.
And when he went to church I went to church.
When he'd ring that bell I'd gone on up there.
I said, Mom can I go to church now?
And she said yeah go ahead on.
And I'd go up there.
I'd get a chance to play the piano.
I could play the piano by ear.
And just had a good time.
And then there was another lady named Miss Molly Richardson.
She used to have a sunshine band in her backyard every Saturday evening.
And she sat on a hill and we had cool eight and cookies.
And then there was another lady named Miss Koramartin.
She used to do the Sacramento bread and wines once a month.
So the Saturday before we had that after I got up pretty good side I would go spend Saturday with her.
And I put it get all that stuff prepared.
We had a lot of fun and wake up everybody in the community laugh.
They would say, Kettle with Martin's house.
So that was my Christian experience was something awesome that I didn't really understand until I was about 45 I guess.
And it came after about five or ten years of seeking what salvation was all about.
And I realized that I had probably been saved since I was like four years old.
But I just didn't understand fully what it was all about.
I'm sure we'll come back to that thing.
I want to ask you too about Phillips County, Arkansas.
That was obviously the location of the Elaine Massacre.
1919.
I wonder if was that a part of your awareness as a child that the county had that specific history of a race massacre?
It came up probably when I was in my middle teens.
We were working down there.
And one of the things I noticed was the earth was cracked and it was hard.
At the temperature outside was in the 80s and 90s.
It was like the ground would just crack like parchment.
And when your whole hit it was like, Ding! Something like that.
And I was like, why has this ground so hard?
I just, I hated to go down there.
And after a while with the children complaining, they would begin to tell us about
the earth.
It's probably from the blood that's in the earth.
It was like, why is it blood in the earth?
And they shared with us about the massacre down there.
And the race right and everything.
Was anybody in the community active in the NAACP?
Not in West Helena, Arkansas that I was aware of.
Personally, I never heard of the NAACP until about 1965.
Right.
Well, I didn't see, I started working with SNCC around 1965.
1957 when they had the the Little Rock Nine.
Even though I lived two hours away in today's transportation system.
If the news came then, I'd never heard anything about it.
We didn't have TV.
We had our first electricity in our house in 1958.
And it was over there.
But didn't come up at church.
And no black newspaper in the community.
And your mother, as you said, couldn't leave you.
Right.
Tell me about, you mentioned earlier that you had a strong sense,
even as a child of 10, 12-ish, that you didn't want to spend your life in that world
that you wanted to graduate from high school and go on.
And you said a little bit more about, did you have a sense of what going on from there might mean?
I really did.
And I just knew that the life I was living in that wasn't what I wanted to do.
Well, I guess you did say that you had some extended members of your extended family
who would say had gone north to West.
Right.
It was like Pittsburgh.
And I guess in 1961, my oldest sister, she went to Mississippi
to attend Mary Holmes Junior College.
And of course, we all worked diligently to get her in that college.
She went there for two years.
And she was sick.
But she was a very strong Christian young lady.
After her second year there, she went to Columbia University in New York City.
And she was studying there.
And that was in 1963.
And she died while she was there.
And I think that for me, that was like,
it was probably my disconnect from pursuing education at a higher level.
Because even in the schools that I grew up in,
Black folks have their own look-ass system.
That if you don't look a certain way, and your skin colored and light enough,
and you don't come from the right family background,
you get discriminated against as much there as you would in the white community.
So, and that was my experience in school.
It didn't matter what my grades were or how I excelled in one level or another.
And I had to fight through that in my senior high school play.
Because, you know, talent speaking, I had the arts.
I could sing.
I could memorize what I needed to memorize to get a party in a place.
I'm like that.
I was good at spelling.
And I liked competition, you know.
But I got fought so much in that that if you don't want me to excel over here,
then I'm just not even going to try over here, you know.
And my worst subject in school was math.
But fortunately, my teacher was a very nice man.
I know where forgetting his name was William Rush.
And he went on to get a PhD in mathematics.
And after I graduated from high school, I met him when he was writing his thesis.
And I got to type a thesis for him.
I will come back to the particular your high school because I really want to talk some more about that.
Okay.
We're back after just a quick break.
Let me ask you about, did you mention a moment ago that very little news came into the community
through the 50s anyway and got electricity in the home.
Did news of the emerging direct action phase of the movement after 1960?
Did that come into your awareness?
Sit ins and protests around the country in the early 60s?
Only because of people like Myrtle Glasgow and Howard Himmelbaum.
Tell me about those folks.
I think Howard Himmelbaum was the first group to come through then.
He came through with a man named Jim Jones from Louisville, Arkansas.
I think Bill Hansen may have been with them.
It was four or five of them.
And they came and got a meeting with one of the local churches to tell, you know, share with us what they were doing and everything.
At that time, the focus was voter education and trying to abolish poll tax because at that time,
when people went to vote, they had to pay a dollar to register the vote.
And most of them couldn't even write their name.
They just did an X and of course they vote probably got flipped on to the side of the minute they turned around.
If they waited till then, they probably did it in their faces.
So I went to all these meetings.
And they wanted to know, you know, if I would work with them and all that, and of course, I said, you know, you have to go ask my parents.
And they did and got permission for me to work with them.
And I was probably one of the few girls in the community that just stepped up and did.
So I remember another man that was there, Jerry Casey.
He was one of the first young men to get involved.
And at that time, we had moved to West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
We was not in Lexa.
We moved to West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas in 1964.
And there was 1965 coming into that school year of 65, 66, I believe.
And the people, especially the black fathers, they were afraid because they knew that that meant the white community was going to begin to backlash on everything that happened.
And the families would have to suffer and stuff.
So my dad was like, you need to be careful messing around with them.
And he was like, you know, I don't know.
He was like, you know, I'm just, you know, I just want to protect you.
And there was a lot of clients.
And they were very much so they did some drive by,
what's it called, Molotov cocktails that they do at the Civil Rights Workers' Places where they lived.
And if it hadn't been for like a poll or something that was right there to block it when they threw it, it would have went into the house that happened on several occasions.
Then they started harassing the Civil Rights Workers by arresting them for being vagrants.
And taking them to jail.
And of course, you know, you had to come up with money.
And they knew that these most of them were either college students or college professors that was just there for the summer, maybe.
But most of them after they got there, they may not have stayed in West Helena, Arkansas, but they went somewhere else and continued to do the work that they were doing there.
We had people come in as a result of the first group.
We had a Julian Bond came, Andrew Young, Stokely Carmichael.
I want to say, Eldridge Cleaver and Marion Barry, they came through there.
Most of them they'd come in like we'd have a meeting for two or three days in a church.
The other thing they realized when my back, I'm the person that sat on this store front every day.
Every day, got everybody in West Helena, Arkansas to come by and sign my petition to abolish poll tax.
And there was an assignment that Howard Hemmerbaum gave me to do who later on became my husband.
We realized that people couldn't read or write.
So we got one of the churches to allow us to teach people how to read and write and specifically to learn how to sign their name.
So when it came time to vote they could register, fill out that application because one of the things that came up was the white community was trying to force people to have to fill out application out,
which is where that voter education application came from.
So in order to do that you needed to know how to read and specifically you should at least know how to sign your name.
You could get somebody else to fill out application out for you, but you needed to sign your name.
So we got one of the churches.
I think it was first Baptist church that let us use their basement.
And a couple of the civil rights workers would work with them on reading and writing a couple of nights a week.
And so things like that we had to change around because we get word that the white clan or whatever they call itself, not all of them would, you know, they wanted to fit into that name with just vigilantes.
They would wait till they got dark and try to come through them and bring physical harm to the different ones.
Let me, this is, I want to spend even more time here talking about all this history and yet more detail.
Can you, can you take me back to, I think the, as I have, as I've read and you can tell me this, this sounds right or not, that the, that the snake folks, and you've mentioned a few of them,
Howard Hemelbaum, Jim Jones, Bill Hansen, others, first came into Helena, Arkansas, and West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, as I have it in the spring of 63 and the first demonstration sort of active protests in Helena, Arkansas.
For November of 63.
It may have been because I know I've spent a whole year after the voter registration because I didn't get out of high school to 66.
So I was reflecting back that that had to be before 64.
I know it was a guy named James Heel, Stanley Tillman, and I think Michael Simmons came with that group.
Some of those guys were one, one I was from Portland, one I was from Seattle, and Mike I think was from New York.
But I remember Stanley Tillman was athlete, and he spent a lot of time getting to know me.
I wonder about him sometimes now, but he asked me if I had, if it was any sports that I did, that I wanted to do that I had never been able to do it.
I said, well, I always wanted to learn soccer, and a couple of times, at Eliza Miller High School, we tried to get a little soccer team going, but a lot of people didn't seem like they were interested in it.
And I said, I'd like the bowl, too, so we do y'all have a bowl in there, and I was like, you ever there on that black folks go there.
Because at that time when they came on the streets, you still had water fountains that had whites only on it, and signs on the bathrooms and stuff, whites only.
If you were blessed enough to be able to drink water, use the bathroom in some places, it would have colored.
And so Mr. Tillman came up with this idea of one day that he was going bowl.
And I told my mom, Mr. Tillman's going to teach me how to bowl, mom.
Is it okay if I go? She was like, yeah, you can go.
So we went to the only bowl in that alley we had.
It's between Helen and West Helen, that area is called Midland Heights.
So we went in.
He knew all of the ins and outs of bowl, and so he went up to rent the shoes, they wouldn't rent them the shoes.
He said, we need a lane.
She's like, well, you can't bowl without shoes.
He said, yeah, sure we can.
Are you going to let us have the lane or not?
So she let us have the lane.
We got over to the lane.
He said, take the shoes off.
We kept our socks on and we proceeded the bowl.
I got to chance the bowl the whole game before the police showed up.
This is before after the police showed up.
Excuse me.
Ask your question again.
Was this before or after the Civil Rights Act at pass?
This is before the Civil Rights Act at pass.
Yes.
Mr. Tillman, I just wanted to ask, was Mr. Tillman white or black?
He was black.
He was a big guy about six, three, probably way to 200 pounds.
He was a fairly attractive young man, pleasant guy.
He wasn't threatening when you saw him.
When the police got there, they tried to intimidate me by asking me my name and who my parents were and stuff like that.
I didn't have no fear for any being.
Never did.
And I said, why are you on my name?
He said, who are your parents?
And everybody knew my dad is bigum.
But he was like six, one, weight about 180 pounds.
His mom described him.
He was tailimating.
So he was like, oh, I know bigum.
And he told me, oh, you out here, I said he does.
Well, I don't think he know what you're doing.
And he made us put on our shoes and leave.
We didn't try to fight back and things.
We just put on our shoes and left.
My first game ever in life, I bow 98.
Were you surprised that you got...
Actually, no, the surprise that they let you bow in the first place.
But since they wouldn't let us have shoes.
But Mr. Tillman, I guess, kind of shocked the lady that was waiting on us
that she didn't know how to deny us the lane, even though she had denied us the shoes.
So she let us have the lane.
And he was like, you know, real bold in a way.
Did it came back to the first...
How did you first hear about these young civil rights workers coming into the community?
I don't remember.
They just started popped up.
And to some of the ladies, folks.
For example, you just called him Mr. Tillman, but he wasn't that many years older than you were.
Well, he was in college and he may have even graduated from college.
I was still in high school.
So these early 20s and you were 15-ish.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So I don't know.
I guess just because they were bigger than me.
Well, that's a lot older.
And of course, they didn't want me to call them Mr. either.
But, you know, that was the train.
People older than you, you know, you greeted them as Mr. and Mrs.
But tell me about these folks and how you began to make sense of them
because they're coming in to take on the civil rights fight.
It's pretty difficult and dangerous work.
So how did you begin to come to understand these people?
Talking to them, we had meetings in their homes, you know,
to explain what it was that we were trying to do.
And I don't remember any of them even mentioning the Little Rock, Arkansas 9
in our communication.
They may have, it may have escaped me because I may have had this ton of vision
about how I could solve my problem right then, West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, you know.
But we came to Little Rock, Arkansas within the first probably 12 months
after they were there because I remember coming to a meeting in Ferndale, Arkansas,
which is a little community west of here.
It was a Presbyterian village and we went there and had like workshops every day for like two or three days.
And there were quite a few people from my community that went because I know I had a cousin that was there.
There was like nine or ten years older than me.
And he was married as a matter of fact.
And because we tried to get the whole community in there,
but people weren't as stick-tuitive as I guess I was because I wanted to be in everything that was going on.
I wanted to know what was going on.
I was played out.
I participated in, after I graduated from high school, we had different sit-ins
and demonstrations here in Little Rock, Arkansas to open up the state capital.
And people got pitched out on their faces, I mean, literally.
How was the cafeteria?
Yes.
And they threw mustard gas bombs on us.
You mentioned earlier that in the bowling alley incident that you didn't fear any man.
Do you think it was just a part of...
How did you come to be a person who didn't have fear in situations like that?
Do you have a sense of that?
I think it was probably...
In Lexa, even though the separation was there,
there was a certain like camaraderie between the blacks and whites that lived there.
There was a support in times of crisis that it seemed like both sides of that track could come together.
And like the musklinis, the way they treated people, they were just nice people.
You know, Mr. Hometized, you had wanted to families that stuck out on both sides of the track that could say,
no, I'm better than you.
You know what I'm saying?
But it was a rural, small community.
Had our own post office, had our own railroads station, we had our own garage, we had our restaurants.
We were like a self-sustaining place.
And even if you went there now, you were like, this place got stuck in time.
But some people are going back there to leave.
What do you think the total population was?
It probably was 2000 people, something like that.
And the racial split would have been approximately...
Maybe in about even.
Yeah, because I think the county back in those days, the county overall was about 56, 57.
Yeah.
And why the move to a cell?
Probably just my parents getting older, wasn't so much focused.
And then we had two older children who were gone.
One had died, one was... had just signed up to go to Vietnam.
The oldest son.
So then the next oldest daughter, she was a special needs child.
And then the next oldest child was my sister who was a year older than me.
So we were all kind of young.
And I think that probably is what caused us to move to West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
Because it was like more modernized.
But even in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, we wind up going to the cotton field again.
And that wasn't a very pleasant thing.
I think, sure, left I got there.
I was in the cotton field one day.
We went on a bus to a place called Snow Lake, Arkansas, Arkansas, which is on the other side of Elaine.
And five young men attempted to rape me.
And the water boy happened to come through when they was hollering.
Me, don't the house, me, don't the house.
And it's one very muscular young man.
And he was a football player.
He stood up in my back with his knees.
And of course, I suffered for the next 20 years.
So I finally had to have some surgery behind all that.
And I was so mad.
I wanted them dead.
I wanted them locked up.
And I know it was the Lord.
Because when we got ready to leave that field,
the bus got stuck.
When we was trying to get the bus out, the steering wheel came off the steering column.
We didn't get out and died at about one or two o'clock in the morning.
And when we passed the police station in West Hill,
and I was going through because I wanted that bus driver to stop
and let me go in there and turn their men.
He wouldn't do it.
So we went home.
I told my mom about what had happened.
And you could hear folks screaming and hollering all over the community
because their parents was beating their parents.
And I guess about two or three days later, my daddy came in the house.
And I was laying down.
I was hurting.
He walked in and said,
has my, he had a little name.
He used to call a lot of his pets that I won't say on camera.
He's like, has my little son, son, son.
And I was like, I was just hollering my daddy to say,
get my baby out of here and take her to the doctor.
I didn't know what shape I was in until I was headed to the doctor.
They had the ambulance come, getting me.
And when that ambulance went across the railroad tracks, I almost died.
And I was in the hospital for like three weeks behind that.
So.
This was after your move to West Hill.
And there was another thing that helped me to want to just get out of there.
You said these were five white teenagers.
No, they weren't white.
These were black guys who had gone out with the group to work in the fields.
And so that hence that's when you said that we could,
so the words spread that they had attempted this sense of the parents came after a conversation.
Yeah.
Can you, can you tell me a little bit about your impressions of Jim Jones,
Hurricane Bomb, Jerry Casey?
I looked up to all of those guys.
They were like, Johnson.
I guess now in the way I would describe them,
they were all my Moses, you know.
Someone who came to bring relief and liberty,
to not only to me, but to the whole community.
And it just seemed like the community didn't wrap themselves around these people enough.
And I guess if I had got a sense of everybody being on board with them,
I probably would have changed my whole attitude about wanting to leave.
But after two and a half years, I didn't see that.
So when it was my time to go, I left.
And as a matter of fact, when I left,
me and Howard Himmelbaum was secretly engaged,
but I wasn't waiting on him.
I said, I'm gone.
If you want to marry me, you're going to come where I am.
I sure did.
I went to DC.
And got employed two or three days after I got to DC
with the Head Start program, went into training,
and did very well.
We'll come to that too.
If you would, still some more details about the campaign and the West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
You worked extensively on the effort to gather signatures to remove all the tax.
And we were successful.
How did that go?
Can you describe that whole project?
It was lonely.
Because it was nobody ever to me, most of the time.
I just sat on this one man's front porch of his business.
I can't remember if I think it was Mr.
I don't know what it was that means, man.
Oh.
I can't remember his name.
I was going to boys.
I sat on his storefront with a little table in front of him in the chair.
The sheet that's all he had to do was put their name on the petition to abolish it.
If they couldn't write their name, they'd put an X and I wrote their name for him.
I guess I did that for two or three weeks.
I'm like that until we felt like we had everybody's name on them.
And doing that time was when Howard Himmelbaum proposed to me.
Do you want to talk about how I'd be very interested if your couple were doing it?
Talking about building this relationship with a young white man in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas in the...
He was very secretive.
It was secretive to us.
Let me put it like that.
But it wasn't such a secret to most people that was around us.
Because when two people care for each other, everybody knows it.
You think you hide it, but you're not hiding it.
As far as in the black community was concerned, maybe one or two people was concerned about it from the black community.
There was a couple of young men that had tried to talk to me before Howard came on the scene.
And what I've made to statement said, so you're going to take a white man over a black man?
I said, I haven't taken any man.
And we just left it at that.
Then I had an older guy who was one of my dad's friends, or supposed to be one of my dad's friends.
He saw me going to church when Sonny Moore and decided to make a derogatory statement to me.
And when I got back home, he was sitting on my front porch talking to my daddy.
So I just stopped right there and told my daddy what Mr. Ernest said to me when I was on my way to church.
And he got the threat of his life that day.
But...
How'd your parents weigh that circumstance?
My relationship with Howard.
My mom loved Howard.
My dad probably did too, but you know how you dads have your eyes way of expressing your feelings and sentiments and everything.
My dad was afraid for me.
That was really the bottom line when I asked him later on, you know, how did he really feel about me being in the civil rights movement and everything.
He was afraid.
He was afraid that his daughter was going to get hurt.
Well, he was very afraid.
He said it's for Howard. He liked Howard.
He said he didn't feel like he would have treated him any differently than a black man.
But my mom, she made sure that Howard knew how she felt about it.
She thought we was married before we got married. She did tell me that later on.
When I invited her to come to my wedding, she was like, I thought y'all's already married.
But we weren't, you know, we just worked close together and everything.
We went on different trips as we had marches and things like that to go to.
I'm trying to remember if he was in Memphis when Martin Luther King got killed.
But I know Myrtle Glasgow and I was there together.
We shared rooms with Stokely Carmichael.
I was just cleavering a couple of other guys that was there.
Howard may have been somewhere else because there was a whole bunch of different type of activities and marches and things that was going on during that time.
Go ahead.
Going back to the full text since there were four white people that probably affected them as well.
Were you also getting the assignment to show them the next couple of things?
It was just a focus on the West tellin' the community, that segment that was covered like a community called New Edition, then West tellin' it's self.
And see, the thing you have to understand about poll tax to mine the standing.
White folks didn't have to pay poll tax.
Right. It was meant to hinder the blacks from being able to vote.
It wasn't about that one way it was about.
We never arrested anyone.
Before you moved away.
I would arrest one time I was because I was hungry.
Excuse me.
Okay, we're back after a short break.
Let me ask.
Were you about to talk about arrests?
Oh yeah.
One time I was down home.
It was after I had left and I was married at the time.
And of course, you know, the struggle continued on for a bunch of years and still do.
But actually active as part of SNCC and then a group that we created here in Little Rock, Arkansas called the Black United Youth.
We would still go to West tellin' the Earl, Blackville (?), McGehee.
Wherever there was an unrest and still the Jim Crow Law, you know, being enforced against our people.
We went down to West tellin' the one summer to work the whole summer. That was the idea.
So after we had been down there, I guess about three, four days, we didn't have any money.
And we were hungry, we were tired, we were hot, you know.
And even though my parents lived there, you know, my parents were very poor.
We'd been poor all of my life.
I said, well, let's just go ask them for something to eat.
So we went into a grocery store.
I think it was a big star.
We went into the grocery store and I asked for the manager, told him who we were, what we were doing.
And we was just hungry, we was wanting to give us some meat and bread, you know.
They wouldn't give us anything. They had this whole store full of food, you know.
And I said, well, I think I'll just give me some bread and meat.
And that's what we did.
And the call of police on us took us to jail.
And I got to jail and they found out who I was. They wouldn't got my daddy.
Brought him back up there.
I said, girl, what are you doing?
You get picked up for stealing food. I said, dad, I did not steal the food.
I went in there and I asked for it and they wouldn't give it to me.
So I just took what I needed to eat. That was it.
I didn't try to hide it, you know.
Of course, they let us go because they knew my dad and they knew my upbringing and everything.
He said, I don't know what I'm going to do with you.
Was that a black or a controlled store?
It was a food change, you know.
And the police officer said, you better be glad people know your dad.
But I said, you know, we all grown up to believe that when you need some, you ask people for it.
And they have it to give. Then they should share it with you.
I said, you out and do that. I said, you taught me that, but that's not what you're doing.
Let me ask about the wider SNCC effort in the Delta in those years.
Did you have, did you go with SNCC folks in places like Golden Forest City for demonstrations?
Or did you pretty much in the high school years where you sticking around West Helena, Arkansas?
I stuck around West Helena, Arkansas and the good work long was in Gould, Arkansas, Arkansas and I think it was Laura Foner.
They were both in good area. We had people in good, we had people in Little Rock, Arkansas, Arkansas, people in West Helena, Arkansas, people in Pine Bluff, Arkansas.
But that was later for a city came like after I was out of high school.
I think they had tried to go into for a city a couple of times.
And I think the very first time they went through there was a terrible shootout.
And I think that's why people kind of backed off, you know.
Even in the difference between Helena, Arkansas and West Helena, Arkansas was in such contrast that the young man James Heal that I was telling you about.
He went to Helena, Arkansas to do some work and they arrested him and the judge would everybody sitting in the court threatened him by saying.
Because he was 21 years old. He already had a master's degree. I believe in engineering. He said, Nigger.
If you're smart enough to have a master's degree at 21 you ought to be a smart enough Nigger to get the hell out of Helena, Arkansas before you find yourself floating up like Nm. Heal.
That's what he said, Torn. There was Judge Hester.
And that young man left right after that too.
Did you? You mentioned that one occasion when you were coming up when your father and other men in the black community set out of guard and armed guard to protect that young man.
Did your father and other men in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, did they have to step forward or organize themselves in that way to provide some protection to black people in any West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas?
They probably did but we didn't know about it. If things came up, there's this group called the Masons, which is basically the Masonic large disin and community.
And I think that's the force that comes together. And there's not a whole bunch of mouthwork that goes on. People just come together and take action and do what need to be done.
Let me ask you two about when when Snick arrived in Helena, Arkansas, you had mentioned earlier that it would be a mistake to think about the black community always in these instances as being perfectly unified in their opinions because there's a lot of different perspective.
So I'm curious about your recollections about how different parts of the black community reacted to the right or Snick because some people welcomed them and some people didn't.
And some just ignored them like they didn't exist.
About the pastors, what was their actions in?
Some of the pastors received them. A lot of the churches in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, the pastors didn't even live there. They lived in Memphis or they lived in Mississippi and they drove in on Friday or Saturday.
So they had a great escape, so to speak. It was the deacons and the mothers of the church that more or less you had to deal with to get into the church itself.
Who helped the Snick folks find a freedom house?
They never had a freedom house in Helena, Arkansas. They had one in West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas.
And then we had, I think we had two or three because murder, eventually, like set up her own personal home there.
And then the guys had a house and the young women had a house.
But most of the young women, we would try to set them up in homes where there was a father and a mother, secure living situation.
Because when murder first came, she actually lived in the house with us.
And that's the thing that impacted her so much about my family, the love that she experienced there, even in our poverty, stricken state.
She was just amazed how we could open up our arms and our home and everything and receive a total stranger into our home.
But that was the way my parents were.
I lost the uncle because our family just believed in helping people.
And he allowed a hobo, we call him hobos then, not homeless people, but because you didn't stay in that state.
The idea is that you would recoup.
So you help a man along the way until he could get back on his feet and this man woke up in the middle of the night and split my uncle's head with an axe and an axe bounced off of his head to his wife's head to his one of his children's head.
Because he was the only one that actually died.
But he'd never stopped my family from extending a helping hand to people.
Can you tell us about Mertel and her live on her?
She came to work in the summer program with SNCC.
She must have been 64. She came out Oakland, California in Little Old Boo got never seen a Volkswagen before in my life.
And of course Mertel was when we saw she was a white woman.
But she was actually a black woman. Her hair was long and curly, you know.
You're very fair. And we were just fascinated with the little bitty car.
She decided she wanted to stay but she needed a place to stay.
Me and her just, I guess we hit it off immediately.
She became my big sister that I had lost like a year or two before she showed up.
And she wound up staying with us and we got close and close.
Eventually, you know, she moved out of us. I guess she got comfortable in the community.
She rented her a little house up the street from us.
And I could go to them and visit her and help her to cook and stuff like that.
She was kind of a vegetarian all of her life.
So she was in the right community to get all the vegetables she wanted.
But when she'd go somewhere, I would get her to ask mom to let me go with her.
That's how I got to travel. Because it was just me and the guys I wouldn't went.
You know? No, that's my daughter. And then after a while after my mom,
then we got to know them real good.
She said, y'all better protect my baby now.
You look after her. That's my baby.
So because of your experience in the whole movement,
change quite a little, something.
It did. I got a chance to go to Atlanta to different marches and things
that was going on there fighting against people being refused to entrance into colleges,
universities and stuff like that.
I think I spent about a week over there one year.
I was like, I'd never seen anything like it in my life.
I don't know who this, it may have been the president of one of the black colleges over there
that we spent like three or four days in their home.
But it was like constant meetings and planning and strategizing.
It was interesting.
This is what I was still in the last time.
Yeah, it was before I moved.
Those meetings you were just traveling around Atlanta?
Yes.
Did you have a sense in these years of the tensions that were emerging in SNCC?
Obviously, I'm sure you did.
And I feel like I'm sitting in Bremen.
Is it Greenwich?
Greenwicher are trying to leave SNCC's Arkansas program forward.
Yeah, I heard a little conversation's going on.
I guess I didn't enter into any of it because I just felt like it was something that would pass.
Everybody was in the back in the struggle for the same reason.
You're going to have little squabbles like little children.
You fight this hour and the next hour you're okay.
And then sometimes when you're dealing with pastors too, they have another way of looking at stuff
that you have to learn how to get past.
And Bill, he was like a...
He'd say what he had to say and then he would just go on off.
Bill hasn't.
And he had his own family.
So he had his privacy that he had somewhere to go and just block everything else out.
So you never knew unless you were with him what was going on.
And it's hard and the same thing with Rev. Ben Grinage.
Bill hasn't had married.
You're the busier tonight.
So they were married by the time you were there.
They were married when I met them.
Yeah.
And some people, you know, in my heart, I guess I just knew they weren't going to stay around long because
it was sort of like with Jim Hill when he got threatened and he left.
You know, I could appreciate him leaving that and wanting to leave.
But I could appreciate him leaving.
There was his life and he had to do what he thought was best for himself.
But everybody has a family.
They had somewhere to go.
If they didn't come to live, they came to see what they could do to help and change things in our community.
And there were some effective changes.
When I graduated from high school and went to DC, I spent what, six months.
I actually I spent almost a year there.
I did spend a year there because I didn't get married to a March of 67.
It was getting married and continually living in the struggle.
Being cautious not to walk down the street, holding hands and stuff like that.
That was really when it became alive to me after we got married.
I'm like, you know what, if I can't be myself, I may as well not be living in this world.
So people just had to deal with who I was and who I was married to.
And if they wanted to be ugly, that was okay.
You know, if I felt like I needed to respond to it, I did.
If I didn't need to respond to it, I didn't.
So, and after a while, I mean, we had enough friends that we could socialize with
that running into the negativity of some periodically, it really didn't bother.
It didn't bother me. I don't think it bothered Howard.
I don't because in the Black and White community, we developed a lot of friends.
We did.
After one last question, then we'll move on to past 66 and reach some of those, some of that history.
How did you balance all your involvement in the movement with getting finished through high school?
Was there a lot of...
Just participating in things that was going on in the community at night,
staying on track with school during the day, you know.
If there were activities outside of the community, usually it was on the weekend.
If it was something during the week, then I just didn't participate in it, you know.
And I guess in my last three months or so of high school,
I don't know if we did that much traveling.
We may have, I know it's always something going on in the community, you know.
Every night and then, somebody would get threatened.
We have to deal with that.
Stand guard.
We could...
With Jerry Kasey being on the team and being one of the young men from the community,
he had friends and family that he could call upon to help give oversight and protection and security around one of the freedom houses.
That was...
It was just one house.
They just two or three times.
I know they tried...
They shot into it once.
They threw a couple of modest off-cocktails at it a couple of different times.
And because they were nearby, I think after a while they realized that people were looking, you know,
back in these places where the guys were living and everything and they begged out.
But it's...
Like Michael Simmons, I know he was one, he didn't make no bones about it.
He said, man, I'm not down up in here for nobody, you know.
You know Michael.
But he was just a down-to-earth type person.
So I think he stayed like one summer and then he left.
Well, that recollection brings to mind, of course, the whole tension inside SNCC, especially in these years, 64, 65, 66.
The whole... the questioning about the whole theory and practice of non-violence and it's that.
Yeah, I remember that because of...
I'll decide to help Martin Luther King.
And Martin positioned us to get killed all the time.
You know, his activities positioned people to get killed.
There's no question about it.
And SNCC's focus was non-violence.
And of course, H.R. Brown and the Black Panther Party came out of that because some people were saying, I'm picking up my gun.
You know, this killing of blacks got to stop.
And so the Black Panther movement came out of that.
What was it?
The (Cornell) Black Liberation Front came out of it with the students coming out of Cornell University with the gun, strapped around them and stuff, which one of those young men was from Little Rock, Arkansas, it would feel.
You probably know him, don't you?
I think he lives in Chapel Hill, doesn't he?
What was this for?
Oh, I do actually know that.
You see, it was Ed Laredixon.
And Eric's somebody, I don't know what Eric's last name was, but it was the three young men that was on the front of that paper.
They all came, the two of them came home with Ed when he came.
And I think they may have stayed here year or two before they actually left.
And when they left, Ed Laredixon came to North Carolina to further his education and actually got married and lived there for several years.
It may still be there.
But those, I guess there was part of the reason why I was in Memphis when Martin Luther King got killed.
Yeah, can you tell me about it?
From 66 through 68 and then we'll even go beyond that.
So you left in May of 66 to Washington.
Right. And stayed up there until actually that Christmas of 66.
And right after Christmas I came to Little Rock, Arkansas and me and Howard planned our wedding and went to New York and March, got married, stayed up there for six weeks.
Then after that just came back and kind of.
I was going to school to become a key punch operator with Opportunities Industrialization Center, which was the Opportunities Industrialization Center that was a new organization to the South anyway to try and help blacks acquire vocational skills where they could get into the job market and make a decent living.
So I got in that class so I could get me a skill and go to work.
And of course I became a.
Trying to look for the name for it.
I was suing people left and right for not hiring me and I knew I was qualified and I was passing the test to get the jobs and stuff.
I won a couple of major lawsuits in Pulaski County for class and I just because I was black but because of women and blacks.
Class action.
And plus county just for the record that's here.
He's bright.
And one of those companies was AMF Inc Inc and the other one was National Old Line Life Insurance Company.
And AMF Inc actually left Arkansas and went to Israel after leaving open up their company over there.
I found it out in the last couple of years.
And National Online was I mean that was a major major when for women and blacks because they had a lot of women working for them.
What did you think of filing the suits in 1967?
Well since I was up there.
It's just up here and how we came back here.
Right.
I graduated from Opportunities Industrialization Center that same year I believe was.
And I got a job with the State Capitol as the first black office work in the administration office through much toll.
Well because prior to that there was the whole episode of...
I'm not even able to eat there and the cafeteria was still closed and everything.
When I started to work there though I was I was hired to work in the Motor Vehicle Department.
Very tough area to work in.
You know when you go and purchase a vehicle and you had it at that time it was a three-part paper that was like four by five or something like that.
And every one of those pieces of paper had a different hand right now because the individual was the one that filled it out.
We were allowed three mistakes per batch and then each batch was in a way from 300 to 500 pieces of paper.
Well Miss Carrie Hommebaum was up to the task but my director just didn't want me there.
And God had positioned in the computer environment a young man that we were friends of his family.
In the very first name my husband picked me up they took his detags off the vehicle and ran check.
I found out I was married to this white guy.
And I guess at that point this man just determined he was going to get rid of me.
So after my 90 day period he told my supervisor to get rid of me and he didn't care how she did it.
Just do it.
So she was very sympathetic and her dismissing me she told me that if I needed a reference she'd be more than glad to give me a reference.
She said but Mr. Luzano wants you out of here.
So okay I didn't part.
I said I'll take the reference letter.
And of course I went home and told my husband what had happened so we went to John W. Walker W. Walker.
I turned to John W. Walker W. Walker and told him what had happened.
We worked up all of the details and we didn't even get the court on that one.
We just went straight to (Winthrop) Rockefeller and gave him all the paperwork and he said,
he's been working on paperwork and he's set up a meeting and everything.
So he I'm going up in there to conference room for the governor.
Great big go everything.
Never been an office this big big table big chairs you know.
And my name on every folder.
So I'm just then observing everything.
Director Luzano comes in the room to see my name on the folder and pick it up.
When I get rid of somebody I don't know about a high back.
And by that time (Winthrop) Rockefeller came in and he said,
well you can just go to your office and get your things in leave because you won't be working here anymore.
So Governor just fired the head of the department about the report.
And it's interesting thing about I wonder what you thought about Rockefeller because he's that curious case.
He's the first Republican governor elected in Arkansas during this session.
And it was because partly because of all the paperwork and that we did.
Exactly.
And it was I think a lot of it was because of the human resource council that is the Elijah Coleman was the head of at the time.
And another young woman his secretary Barbara Grace she was white.
And I think Barbara may have even been from Stuttgart, Arkansas.
So you know people on the team came from all different directions of Arkansas.
Different races, different ideas, but all with a forward vision.
What's your husband working for the Arkansas Council on Human Relations?
I don't know if he was with them or if he was with the Urban League.
I think he did some I think he did like some freelance work for the Arkansas Council on Human Relations.
Because you know people believe it and I think some of the people was like well I don't know we should hire a white man to work for us.
You know they didn't just come out and say it but they didn't want to see a stop and okay.
So he did a little freelance stuff and he finally landed a position with Urban League.
The moment that had it up to human relations.
Right.
And see how it had his way of dealing with things that I think he threatened some people.
And I think Mr. Coleman was one of those people.
He liked him but he wasn't sure he wanted him around.
I lost my thought.
Well you got your job back.
Okay we're back after short break.
You know what I got in my job but let me just back up make this point.
And getting the job they ran me around from the revenue building which was like two blocks west of the state capital.
Back to the state capital about three or four times it was hot.
And they were paving the asphalt which made it even hotter and smelly.
So after about the second time me walking down there and walking back walking down there and walking back.
I decided to take my shoes off.
Not knowing what was going to happen to my feet.
But after I walked down there barefooted and walked back there was a young man on the state capital grounds that knew me.
White man.
He said aren't you Howard Himmelbaum's wife and I said yes.
He said why are you walking with your shoes off?
So I began to explain to him who was going on.
He just sat there and observed everything.
And he put it in the paper.
The paper that he worked for wasn't the Arkansas Democrat or the Arkansas Gazette which is now the Arkansas Democrat.
Wasn't either one of them was another freelance paper.
Maybe in the Arkansas Times I'm not sure.
But he put it in there so that people would hear about it and he called Howard to tell him what was going on.
The story that he wrote was about how you were getting the run around the state.
And you were taking the shoes off just because my feet were getting tired.
Have you been to the state capital?
And it took me like weeks to get all the black tar off my bottom of my feet by the way.
But when they finally got the idea that this woman is determined that she's not going away, they decided to give me the test there at the state capital and the administration office.
And what they gave me, the test on was something that I could have done with my eyes closed literally.
They gave me 30 minutes to take the test.
I had to program my own card and do all this, which I was very proficient at.
I did all that and it took the test four times and I still had time left.
I just got tired of taking the stock.
I got hired to go to work for the Motor Vehicle Department.
After he fired me and he got me to rehired me, then I actually began to work there in the administration office until I quit.
And then there's the irony, as you say, you go to work in the capital. It's the first half of the American working.
And you've got this Republican governor elected with all this black support, which is what gets him into the office.
And then you can't even capture it.
So it was quite an experience though.
And then you and Howard continue your involvement, because as you say, you're going to be in Memphis in 1968.
Well, it's just...
We still formerly, I mean SNCC is really beginning to come apart in 1967-68.
Yeah, but I mean, men, who stayed married until 1978, I believe, was.
I worked most of that time.
But I know what I did.
After I left the state capital, I went and put in an application with Kelly Services.
So I could work part-time.
The way I could not take a job or take a job.
And that worked out fine for me until I got to that point.
You know that I wanted my own car. I wanted this. You know how it happens.
And so I wound up going to work for American life insurance company, I believe, was what it was called.
I worked for them a couple of years, and then I went to work for Southwestern Bell and worked for them for 14 years.
But doing that time between probably 68-69 to 71, it was active in the BUY Black United Youth.
Then traveling to Memphis Atlanta, West Tellenham, McGehee, Arkansas.
Earle, Arkansas, I was in Earle, Arkansas the night that they had decided they was going to force the Black Children to go to.
They closed the Black High School and forced their body to go to the White High School.
Because of the Black United Youth Group, people were coming to Little Rock, Arkansas asking us for help.
We would go to support them.
And it was probably a good thing we were there because I mean they beat people that night.
I was walking by this little old lady and this state trooper came in between us.
And he had his three-fifth of said, Magnum up gone.
He pulled his trigger and said, Ron Nigger, pow, Ron Nigger.
And this little old lady on this walking cane, right?
And he finally reached over and knocked to walking cane out of the mud and knocked.
And I was like, do this man send me over here?
Because he act just like he didn't even see me.
And they were going behind bushes and beating people and I'm walking.
And then this pickup truck comes by, people running, polis shooting, just to scare people.
Because I guess they knew we didn't have any weapons or stuff.
But we really did have weapons.
But they weren't with us. They were in our car.
So we got back to the house.
I believe Ed, Larry Dixon and Eric was with us.
Robert Brawwater, myself, a young woman named Katanga.
And we got back to the house where we had started from.
Of course, everybody had their guns out in Earl.
And I don't remember exactly what year that was, but it was the year they desegregated the high schools.
And of course, like I said, they closed the black high school left the white one open.
And we got back to Little Rock, Arkansas that I had been picked up by these white men on the pickup truck.
And they drove off with it.
So I turned the walker called the governor and the governor sent out the state,
the National Guard to go down and see what was going on and everything.
So they got back to Little Rock, Arkansas because I actually, I became an expert driver because of the movement.
And we were driving a Mustang.
My friend Bob Brawwater had a Mustang.
And he said, carry you driving. I'm riding shotgun.
It was about four or five hours in the car.
I drove, got out of there and got back.
And Howard said, John W. Walker got the National Guard head of the turtle looking for you.
So he said, you better get on the phone and call him.
Because he hadn't picked up a gun.
But the way they were driving, they were driving and knocking people over and stuff like this.
And I had it where it got to him that it happened.
But I called him and they didn't know what was going on.
And then of course they wanted to meet with all of us and find out exactly what had happened and everything.
I mean, it was a crazy thing.
All the marches I had been in, I had never seen anything go as haywire as that.
And through no provocation of anybody that was there, the police just decided they wanted to be bullets.
Tell me, can you tell me about Bobby Brown and the BUY.?
Bobby Brown was like a...
The philosophy was just to protect the black youth, especially in the college environment.
Make sure that they had a student union representation.
And you probably aware of that being from Chapel Hill because that was one of the things that they were fighting for when I went to do them.
Having black leadership within that system, not just putting our children into the institutions of how I learned and have no representation or consideration for that matter.
That's basically what it was all about.
And it had to also start in the high schools since we were now integrating or desegregating all of the schools from all levels.
It needed to be in the high schools as well.
That was our focus and we were trying to get the students to come home and share what's going on in the schools that you know is not right.
If you feel like your teacher is not treating you properly, come share that.
I think the parents kind of blocked that.
We had a few young men that come in, especially from what we call the south end of Little Rock, Arkansas and a few from West Little Rock, Arkansas.
Because their parents seemed to be economically more secure than the children that was in East Little Rock, Arkansas.
East Little Rock, Arkansas was your more poor class of people.
College Station was kind of an isolated black community of its own that was very strong economically and spiritually.
And it used to this day.
And Bobby Brown.
That was Bobbi.
And Bobbi had influence of the street guys.
The street guys were really, really tough.
So Bobby Brown from Little Rock, Arkansas, Bob Broadway from Blackwood, which is like Northeast Arkansas,
who was also a graduate of Philander Smith College.
He was a little.
Yes.
And he was married.
His wife was a teacher.
And he was a news announcer with KOKY-AM, radio station.
Let's take a little break.
We're back after short break for the phone.
Just describing Bob.
Was it Broadway?
And KOKY-AM White.
Yes.
He was a grad by, Broadway was a Philander Smith College.
He worked at KOKY-AM White at the time I met him under the directorship of a man named Larry Hayes.
And both he and Larry were focused on bringing a black perspective to the media.
So that people would know exactly what was going on.
And because of that, him and Bobby Brown became our collaborators together.
But of course, Bob Broadway, the being from where he was from,
he was interested in becoming and planning active part in the movement as well.
So they kind of had some little clashes too, power struggles.
Mainly because Bobby Brown was like hated white folks.
I mean, I just put it out there.
His thing was I hate white folks all on a hand and do it.
And we're all white as man.
We can't work in this world without all the people.
And we have to learn how to work with each other.
And we battle that through getting (Winthrop) Rockefeller elected as governor.
We had factions going on on the inside and stuff like that.
But dealing with what is our alternative?
Okay, let's go talk to (Winthrop) Rockefeller, I'll say.
Let's get to Urban League out the way.
Let's get the Arkansas Council on Human Relations out the way.
Because we don't want nobody selling our vote.
We deal with that today.
And John W. Walker W. Walker was involved in all these negotiations as well.
And he was struggling today.
If you allow certain people to take your words to establish things,
then you get booted out.
And the people don't get served.
So that was our concern and our focus that if we're going to elect this man, governor,
he needs to know what it is that we want, not what y'all want, but what we want.
Bobby, he was a good bodyguard.
He had that possess that was needed for any struggle, for any person in power.
You need somebody that can have the strong arm and know how to communicate to him.
I don't think he was ever able to really bring his vision to the community
where people could receive him.
But there were those of us, and I was one, I respected him for what he brought to the table.
His sister was like a forerunner because of her participation in the Little Rock, Arkansas nine and everything.
I know his family had gone through a lot because of that.
People made, after years, appreciate what happened as a result when you're in it, they're afraid.
And sometimes even the silence is worse than those who are speaking out.
And I know that affected him.
What took you down to Memphis in six years?
Just a few years, Dr. King?
Not so much to hear him is to support him, to be there for protection, to be eyes and ears.
That's basically what we did to increase the view.
A lot of times they didn't want the sisters there because they knew when Dr. King showed up on the scene
there were going to be guns aimed at him.
They knew that.
And like I said earlier, that's why the Black Liberation Army came, that's why the Black Panther movement came.
It was for the protection of a leader, nothing else.
It wasn't to go out and kill white folks.
It was for protection of a leader.
We may not have agreed with all of Dr. King's methods of getting where he wanted to go, but we didn't want to see him dead.
And we all played a part in the struggle and got things accomplished in our own way.
And the wrong people were the closest to him.
That's all I can say because if the right people had been closest to him, I think he would have lived a little longer.
But you can do that bit.
What was your opinion of mine in the late 60s after Dr. King has killed?
And you're obviously married to a white man.
You've met in the movement.
But the movement has changed quite a bit by the late 60s from its early form.
Can you recall your sense of perspective on this society if its prospects were very positive?
I didn't see.
I saw some change, but I didn't see the change I wanted to see.
Wrong people got in office.
Wrong people got the best paying jobs in corporate America.
People got access to high education.
And in all those three categories I just named, I think people very casually forget where they came from and how they got the way they were.
The story was not kept alive.
And those of us who wanted to continue to talk about it like a Bobby Brown or Carrie Himmelbaum, we got put down or pushed to the side.
Don't want to hear that.
America is OK now.
But now we're in 2011 and we know that America is not OK.
What changes did you put that the movement would produce that one emerging?
My personal was economic change.
Blacks in business.
To have the same access.
My struggle was not about being as good as the white man.
My struggle was about, and I think everybody was and people lost focus on it.
It was about civil rights.
It was about holding up the Constitution of the United States of America.
And I saw a shift when people began to come back from the Vietnam War.
I saw a major shift because of the drugs that came with it.
White America became addicted to drugs.
They had to stand before the judge just like black people did.
And white people changed the law to protect their children.
That's what I saw.
That's what I see today.
They just killed Troy Davis.
No evidence whatsoever.
That's not a country that's growing.
And those are the things that people should be talking about.
Not only black people should have been out in the yard, but all people should have been out in the yard.
No, we're not going to let you do that.
You can't do that.
This is 2011.
We don't kill people without evidence.
This is a man just for the record.
This is a man who was executed last week in Georgia by Georgia State authorities
who were reportedly murdered 22 years ago.
Everyone up to and including the former Republican, Attorney General, United States,
petition and state not to move forward with the execution.
How long did you, moving into the 1970s, how long did you have an organized framework for continuing your activism?
How long did the UI persist in an organized form?
I believe up until about 1970, 1971, somewhere in there.
Did you have organized vehicles after that?
No, no more so then.
Most of the things seemed to generate out of Atlanta.
You had the SCLC that had been developed, but that's Southern Christian Leadership Conference.
And there was another group too.
And it's like everything merged into Atlanta and kind of went out from there.
Floyd McKissick, you know, and then of course,
Julian Bond went into politics and Andrew Young went into politics,
Marion Barry went into politics.
And it's, you know, again, it's like the vision was lost with them.
These were great opportunities that we missed.
How did you read Obama's election?
How did I read it?
Can I set an end word on here?
Sure.
I saw in Little Rock, Arkansas looking from Little Rock, Arkansas,
but I could do it nationally, but from a personal perspective,
I saw an omnis in Little Rock, Arkansas.
I didn't see people looking at a man who had achieved acceptance
at a political leader and a possibility to run this country.
It was like there was just a flat out refusal to even look at him
until after the primary.
And I met a fact I sent out an email last week
in a response to a big blast that somebody put out about us coming together
and supporting Obama.
And I suggested that we put our money where our mouth is,
because number one, that's the first thing he needs to be reelected.
And then I shared with them how I felt threatened
when he first ran for office.
When I read about him running and I knew the things
that he had already tried to do and accomplished as a political figure
in America and in the state of Illinois,
I said, you know what?
I can't find any reason why I shouldn't support this man.
After all, I have struggled for in America to get blacks in a position like this.
He fit every category, okay?
And I was offended in several areas.
The first one I was offended in is that we would ask him for a resume.
In 60 years of my life, I've never heard of a president
or a person running for president asked to get a resume.
You need a resume?
No, resume. He was asked for a resume.
The birth certificate came later.
I mean, the only resume you ever spoke about
needed to be an American citizen, right?
Born in America, rather, and beat what?
21, 40.
And he met him.
As long as he was senator,
wasn't nobody questioning where he was from.
You know what I'm saying?
When you were saying the numbness,
are you saying the black community?
Certainly in the white community.
I think I'm saying in the black community.
In the black community here,
maybe it's just because this is a clinton favor or something.
So I had, and they're going to come out here and love it.
But I have my box of memorabilia
where I went online to the Democratic website
and ordered little flag from my vehicle
and signs from my windows and all this stuff.
And I would drive down the streets
and people would look at me like I was crazy.
I got asked to be quiet in a place,
a public place that I spent money
to get my taxes prepared every year
because I was talking about Obama in a positive way.
Wow.
I'm going to show one more time.
I'm going to start with this one.
Okay, we're back.
We have, we're back after short break
and we have a swap of drives,
hard drives further recording.
Miss Young, we're talking about President Obama.
And President Obama,
one thing I would like to say,
is overall I support him.
And I'll say this with no hesitation.
The main reason I supported President Obama
is because he was a black man that was qualified.
Number two, I don't agree with everything President Obama has done
and I probably won't agree with everything he'll do in the future.
But no other President
have I had the opportunity to vote for.
Have I ever agreed with everything that he said it did?
Okay.
And I would say this to black America.
If you can't usher yourself into a spirit of support
and cooperation with President Barack Obama
and you'll probably hear this after the fact.
But if you didn't, you need to examine yourself
because you miss one of the greatest opportunities of your life.
Our parents died for this day.
Our children have died for this day.
Both black, white, Jew, Indian, Chinese, what have you?
Have died for the day to have a black man as a President
of the United States of America.
And for us not to have supported him the way we could have.
And what we lacked admitted or not,
we have done some deliberate things to hinder prosperity
and success in America in the last three years.
Can't deny.
I think as a President,
I would have loved to see him be a stronger Christian.
And not sign some of the things into a law that he has
because they just go against Christianity.
I think people's freedom of speech
have been compromised for the hate word.
But I think it's a trick of the devil.
And people need to fight for their liberty to speak
whatever they want to speak.
And we should be mature enough to either hear it or tune it up.
As a black woman in America,
I've had to deal with that all my life.
So if I want to call a person a faggot
I shouldn't have to worry about going to jail for that.
That's part of my freedom of speech.
If I want to call somebody a nigger,
that's part of my freedom of speech.
My dad called my mom that all the time.
It's a pet word, okay?
So it's about the hero and the giver
and the state that is being used in.
But because America is so called up today
having a black person in office
they want to cut off every liberty you can think of.
Let me ask you about your year in Durham.
I think it was 1971.
It was interesting.
I had several reasons for one to go.
I think a lot of my reasoning had to do with acceptance.
Had nothing to do with the fact that I was married to a white man
at the time because I was married to Howard Himmelbaum at the time.
Part of it was acceptance.
I needed to know black folks.
The black folks that I knew growing up in West Helena, Arkansas
didn't like me.
There you go.
Now with people who are supposed to be fighting for equal rights
and leveraging justice for all.
I had to understand that just because the name of the school
was Malcolm X Liberation University wasn't a black white thing.
But it's about education.
And understanding who you are.
We actually studied the different races
and the different ethnic groups in Africa and Mexico.
We learned martial arts.
We learned about self-control and all this.
We looked for opportunities in the community to participate
in different things where we could support.
We even came to Chapel Hill a couple of times with some activities
that was going on over there and participating in those things.
But even there, people couldn't see past color.
And I had a couple of people that didn't appreciate
when my husband came to visit me.
I think it was either Thanksgiving or Christmas.
So I'm the people that didn't know that I was married to a white guy
so it became an issue.
So I said, you know what?
It's time for me to go.
Because it's where racism is.
I don't want to be there.
We are all created in God's image.
And that's how I look at people.
I try not to see white and black.
And if you bring it up, I might look at you and say,
do you believe that Jesus is a Christ?
If you don't believe Jesus is a Christ,
I say, oh, then you are white.
And that's the way I'll treat you.
But if you tell me you believe Jesus is a Christ,
I can't see you white.
Because if you don't have to understand it, it's going to come.
I have one remaining question too.
But are there other issues that we haven't touched on that you'd like to touch on?
No, I don't think so.
I'd like to say this.
It's having the opportunity to sit here and be interviewed by you all.
I would like to thank Murdered Lasco and people like her
who understands that there are people like me out here in the field
who gave all they had to give to the struggle of equal rights for all men
and women, not only in America, but in the world.
And I thank you, gentlemen, for doing a fantastic job.
I'm sure if you think of something when you get home,
that you left out, you know, you can feel free to call me
and we can elaborate on it later date.
But I'd just like to thank the Lord for this opportunity.
And thank the Lord for a wonderful director that I have
in Modern Woodmen of America named Albert Hurst Jr.
Albert T. Hurst Jr.
who gave me time off to come home and do this interview with you all.
One final question on our side.
It's sort of a point of personal privilege,
but also connects to the movement.
You knew someone John W. Walker knew, and that was worth long.
Oh, yes.
The description of work.
Worth Long was an art man, a sweet man.
But he danced to a shownut of different beat.
He was always very pleasant, very respectful.
He kind of flowed with the wind, you know, when he was around you.
He always had a little bag on his arm.
And he was just always pleasant.
He really was.
I never really got to know him because he wasn't around that much
in the area where I was.
But when he would come to West Helena, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas, Arkansas,
he would make sure he came to visit my parents.
Well, it's been a real honor and a privilege.
Miss Young, thank you so much for the warm welcome.
And it's been a wonderful thing to set this down for the collection.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Oh, I got to see it on it.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.